no today there's some real
competition now the shortest version of
this review up front is that the 970 XT
and the 5070 TI go back and forth a lot
depending on the game especially in
rasterization rate tracing Nvidia still
holds an advantage so the quick version
is at 4K Ras without RT for the recap
the 970 XT and the 5070 TI are often
within 6% of each other on either side
that's in F1 cyber Punk Resident Evil 4
Starfield Total War Warhammer 3 dragons
DOA 2 f 1440p and 1080p we saw similar
results depending on the game sometimes
the 970 XD can close the gap a little
bit if it's behind there sometimes it
pulls ahead a little bit just depends on
the situation now interestingly because
the 5070 TI is basically a 4080 V is it
3 or four we're going to go with four it
depends how you count the ti that was UN
launched but anyway because basically a
4080 which is therefore basically a 480
super that means there's instances where
the 970 XT is getting really close to
the 4080 super I think there might have
been one where it passed it but we'll
talk about that in raay tracing it's all
over the place so this is sort of the
downside to it where Andy's got some
real strengths of this one it's also got
some real still present downsides so an
RT AMD has improved massively over its
prior generation the 970 XT definitely
gets uplift over the 7,000 Series in
most instances for RT Nvidia is fiercely
competitive here still uh and AMD for
example gets absolutely crushed in
blackm myth who K with Ray tracing
against Nvidia but it is actually more
competitive now in mixed RT workload
games or sort of mediumweight RT uh
situations depending on what they are so
nvidia's biggest strengths remain in its
feature set generally rate tracing
efficiency in particular power
consumption is pretty effective for
what's output the features get difficult
to measure for example do we measure MFG
as multiframe generation or as multi
failure generation anyway that's the
fastest possible recap of this review
nvidia's had a busy 3 months destroying
the hype that it built for the 50 Series
it really had a lot of ups and downs
that launched I mean for example on the
positive
side but on the negative side there's
been things like the melting 12vt high
power cables the missing RS the the
missing RS on the other C that they
didn't disclose until after they were
discovered the paper launch the fact
that the prices aren't real even from
its own first parties the line on stage
about the 5070 versus the 4090 and
actually we're going to be here all day
if we list all the issues so let's just
move to the 970 XT review before that
this video is brought to you by the
montac hyperflow series of liquid
coolers the montac hyperflow aims to
compete with other affordable liquid
coolers by fighting on price to
Performance in our testing cooler
performance was comparable to others in
its class the AR argb hyperflow has an
illuminated pump block with RGB LED fans
that have quality rubber bumpers for
vibration damping the cooler has a
six-year warranty and supports all
modern Intel and AMD sockets and you can
learn more at the link in the
description below we're to keep this one
really focused today let's start with
the basics and these are RX 970 and 970
XT launch the day after this video goes
up we already posted separate videos
going into the specs and the
architecture of the cards so we'll link
that below but the quick recap is this
AMD has made major changes
architecturally for the rdna 4
generation which is this one there's two
cards there's the 97 in the 970 XD
there's probably going to be another
card later that's lower end the basic
specs of the cards today might feel
familiar to the Vega era the cards are
divided by a 56 cuu or compute unit and
a 64 cuu model with today's focusing on
the 64 and no not that one we'll review
the 9070 later today as well so check
back for that later today for TDP AMD
markets them as 220 Watt and 304 Watts
with board Partners having room to scale
beyond that we'll test this today as
well AMD is using gdr 6 memory at 16 GB
capacity at 20 GBS per second and on a
256bit bust for both cards the vram
alone will be advantageous in heavier RT
workloads something we talked about
yesterday in the 5070 review the
architecture's biggest overhaul that
we're aware of has been in Ray tracing
MD has doubled the ray intersection rate
moved to two RT accelerated blocks with
a shared 128 kiloby memory moved to bb8
and introduced oriented bounding boxes
or obbs to reduce or eliminate false
positives and ra triangle and Ray box
intersections AMD has also introduced a
dedicated Ray transform block to help
with transformation and again this is
all stuff that AMD really needs to
improve on because Nvidia has
successfully sort of manufactured a
category it's really good at which is
real-time R Trac in and Intel even again
sort of makes AMD look bad in some of
those situations with the 7,000 Series
so they needed to make some ground here
and uh and we'll be looking at that
today now for pricing this is a little
difficult lately because it's just like
nothing but for the card that you might
remember as being built entirely upon
and lies 490 performance at
549 impossible without the Four Tops
four ter Ops
of AI we did a quick look at Newegg for
what was in stock
and it was there was nothing it was all
gone so when we checked New Egg
yesterday the only card that was between
$450 and $650 sold first party and not
refurbished was the 7800 XT this is
madness and if it were about 10 years
ago I'd probably kick a video card off
the table and yell something about
Sparta but Madness nonetheless there's
just nothing there the 970 XT and the
970 both should be within this range
tomorrow in theory so we'll have to
check back for that they are also likely
to get scalped like Nvidia what may help
is that there are rumors of Greater
Supply than the 50 Series and likewise
they may be less desirable in the AI at
home segment than the 509s for example
so because the reviews go up before
launch we can't know the scalper or the
availability situation right now as we
film this so uh you'll get to you'll get
to watch and find out but we'll do a
follow-up to talk about all that and see
how the uh the launch shook out either
way we normally dedicate an entire
section to talking about the various
different Alternatives right now at the
same price the short version is that
there are none isn't that fun there's no
options uh and so that makes the section
very short anyway we're just trying to
keep this simple today so let's go
straight into the numbers Dragon stma 2
at 4K is a remarkably strong sh for the
970 XT so we'll start here this is going
to go back and forth a bit in this
Benchmark the 970 XT ran at 70 FPS
average Landing it between the 480 and
the 3090 TI that means that even taking
MSRP at face value for both cards the
$600 970 XT is achieving 95% of the
performance of the $750 RTX 570 TI Prime
but at 80% of the MSRP we want to
caution that this result doesn't always
happen the next game it doesn't
sometimes a 970 XT is worse than a 50 70
so it depends on the game but this is a
great start the frame time pacing is
also comparable meaning that the frame
to frame interval is not noticeably
different to a human player the 970 XT
leads the 700 XT by 14.8% here the lead
over the 570 is 24% at 70 fps to 56 FPS
at 1440p the RX 970 XT nearly ties the
Nvidia RTX 570 TI the ladder of which
only leads by 3% it's measurable but
you'd never notice this difference just
like the 3% of Truth was measurable in
nvidia's 570 equal 490 but you'd never
notice that difference either the lows
are also within variance the 5070 TI is
basically an RTX 480 V3 or 4 depending
on how you count them that means the 970
XT is also punching close to 480 super
levels the 480 super was a $1,000 MSRP
card that replaced a clinically insane
$1,200 MP card before it giving us some
perspective here the last gen Flagship
makes us wish that AMD had something one
step higher as well the 700 XTX still
leads the new 970 XT holding an 8%
Advantage here against the new 5070 the
970 XT leads by 21% the 700 GRE posts an
even larger Gap to the 9070 XT as for
owners on cards like the 2070 or 2070
super here this might be a good upgrade
at 1080p the 970 XT maintained its
relative positioning against the 5070 TI
it's now at 145 FPS average to the 151
result on the $750 MSRP Nvidia model
available on sale for only $150 more
we've never seen an inverse sale where
the price goes up but as they say so
bold strategy cotton let's see if it
pays off for them the 700 XT ran at 134
FPS average in the dragon stock with 2
1080p Benchmark given the 9070 XT and
uplift of 8% as for the 7800 XTX it's
still technically ahead of the new
flagship rdna 4 card but only by 8% now
for Final Fantasy I want to have a very
clear disclosure here the numbers we're
getting are repeatable they are however
lower than what AMD is presenting in its
public slide deck and they don't really
align with the other nonr Trace
performance numbers that we've collected
so we re and everything we've been
looking into it and we're getting the
same results that's why we're going to
present them however we do want to be
clear that they appear to be outliers
and uh so we're going to dig into these
some more and just see if anything
changes thus far we're getting the same
results repeatedly I spoke with d b and
he saw similar results in one of the
games he tested we'll update you all in
a hardware news or the 9070 review or
something we don't think it's our test
setup because it is repeating on both of
the cards but it might be something to
do with the particular scene that where
benchmark marketing or something like
that so anyway we're going to dig into
this but let's present the numbers as
they came out for now at 4K the 97 XT
landed at 68 FPS average unfortunately
for AMD that means that the 970 XT is
worse than the 570 here the 570 leads
the 970 XD by 13.6% with it 78 FPS
average the 570 TI leads by a staggering
43% at 97 fps to 68 whereas Dragon Aqua
2 was a strong position for AMD it's
weak in this game it all depends on the
game itself at 1440p the 970 XT ended up
at only 2 FPS above the 700 GRE
architecturally the improvements just
aren't helping here the 570 TI ends up
at 187 FPS average leading the 970 XD by
34% 570 leads it by 10% let's show how
much of a tennis match it really is and
go back and forth again Resident Evil 4
swings it back the other way at 4K the
970x now holds a 103 FPS average Landing
it nearly tied with the 480 super that's
a great spot for ry's card which it
needs after that Final Fantasy showing
we just saw the 970 XT leads the 700 XT
marginally and leads the 570 by 31% the
570 TI leads the 970 XT by 3 and 1.5%
with the 7900 XTX 23% ahead at 1440p the
970 XT continues to rank alongside
Nvidia the 970 XT is about 5 FPS short
of the 570 TI making for a measurable
but undetectable difference to a human
just like the measurable but
undetectable difference between all of
nvidia's 8,00 480 cards that it's remade
but all of that is assuming the 5070 TI
has all of its RS if it doesn't then
we'd see anywhere from like a 6 to 12%
change in the performance TN the 480
super leads the 970 XT by 5% here the
7800 XTX was also once a $1,000 card and
itself leads the 970 XT by 20% with its
232 FPS result against the new 570 the
970 XT holds a 27% Advantage at 1080p
the 970 XT clocked higher frame rate
than the 700 XT and landed just below
the 5070 TI the 80 leads the 970 XT by
15% which isn't all that much when
considering we've all been GID into
thinking a 80 takes the place of a 1080
TI or something it's not the high-end
it's like a mid-range card since we just
alternated to a title where the XT looks
better let's bring it back maybe the
other way Blackmouth won tends to favor
Nvidia both with and without RT enabled
we'll see if that remains true with the
new architecture at 4K the 570 TI leads
the 970 XT by 12% here it's not as big
of a gap as it could be we'll see how
that maintains an RT but against the
5070 the 970 XT is at least ahead by 14%
compared to the prior generation the 970
XT is about the same as a 4070 TI super
the 700 XTX is a few percentage points
higher frame rate than the 970 XT at
1440p the 970 xt's 83 FPS average result
is matched with good pacing on the 1%
and 0.1% lows it's not better than its
neighbors in a meaningful way but is a
keeping pce properly the 5070 TI leads
the 970 XT by 5% and the 580 leads it by
177% probably calling the 80's existence
into question more than really anything
else here and again that's one with all
of the robs there the 570 ran at 72 FPS
average so the 970 XT is about 10 FPS
higher that also had the 570 above the
7800 XT which the 970 XT has now vaulted
past at 1080p the scaling shifts the 970
XT closer the 7800 XTX the two are
functionally equal in all three metrics
here the 5070 TI outranks the 970 XT on
a technicality but not in an observable
way 1080p seems to squish all these
together Starfield is up now this one
flips it again at 4K the 970 XT leads
the 55070 ti by about 2 FPS just like
we've said elsewhere this is a
measurable but irrelevant difference you
wouldn't notice the 2 FPS you probably
would notice the cost difference though
the 970 XT actually roughly equals the
480 super here and isn't that distant
from the 580 both the 570 TI and the 970
XT are a threat to the 580s already
questionable existence at 1440p the 970
XT is again between the 5070 TI and the
480 super roughly tying the ladder the
7800 XTX has a 6% lead over the 970 XT
here the 570 NTI which is still not
equivalent to an RTX 490 continues to
not be equivalent to an RTX 490 wow
truly wondrous technology we never could
have predicted that at 1080p the 970 XT
now holds a 127 FPS average with lows at
68 and 46 that plans it right between
the 700 XTX and the 570 TI there's not
much difference between these three in
this test 4080 super actually isn't that
different either and the 90 shows that
we do have a little bit more CPU head
room here and actually so does the 490
for that matter which continues to not
be a 5070 just in case we hadn't
mentioned it dlight 2 is up next this is
one of the heavier games in our test
suite at 4K the 970 XT ran at 62 FPS
average which has it just ahead of the
3090 TI it's also 11% ahead of the 5070
the 5070 TI leads the 970 XT by 12% in
this test which matches its gain in
tests were held in advantage in other
words the 970 XT achieves 89% of the
performance at 80% of the listed MSRP
we're reviewing this before the 970 XTS
go on sale so we can't know how much to
adjust for for street price so using the
only one there's any control for that's
kind of how it shakes out at 1440p the
570 TI beats the 970 XT at 130 fps to
118 or about a 10% uplift to the 55070
ti the 480 super is a few frames above
that the 570 is down at 106 FPS average
resulting in an advantage for the 970 XT
of 11% it's equidistant between them AMD
has also improved on it 7900 XT model
the 6700 XT is way down at 61 FPS
average so users on that tier of
Hardware could experience nearly a
doubling in frame rate in some tests
we've been rerunning cyberpunk Phantom
Liberty on a newer version for all tests
so this chart is sparse the 970 XT ran
at 53 FPS average giving it a lead over
the 570 TI's 50 FPS average of 5.8 %
against the 5070 the 970 XD is ahead by
29% maybe more noteworthy is that the
970 XD is technically ahead of the 480
the 7900 XTX meanwhile remains about 9%
higher average frame rate than the 970
XT at 1440p the 970 XT climbs to a
playable 109 FPS average in Phantom
Liberty this is without upscaling or
frame generation just Organic Farm Fresh
frames the 970 XT ends up basically tied
with the 570 TI slightly leading the
4080 and notably leading the 570 we
haven't rerun amd's older stuff in this
one yet time for raay tracing this is
where AMD will really need to prove
itself AMD spent a lot of time talking
about its improvements to ra tracing
blocks and its recent press briefings so
they're clearly aware of the deficit
we'll start with the worst case scenario
it should get better from here
Blackmouth hukan has worked best on
Nvidia Hardware since its launch
especially in R tracing at 4K with
upscaling and R raced the 970 XT ran
with our settings at 29 FPS average
playability isn't important to us right
now just the relative scaling we'll get
to the lower resolutions in a minute
with these settings the 570 ends up
ahead by a large 38% at 40 fps to 29 the
570 TI is 78% ahead of the 970 XD this
is amd's absolute worst case scenario
against last generation AMD is at least
posting large gains the 970 XT
outperforms the 700 XTX by 45% climbing
from 20 to 29 FPS that is a substantial
gain especially considering the XTX was
often slightly ahead of the 970 XT in
raster but obviously there are
situations especially games like this
where you still will have to just
heavily weigh Nvidia if RT and this type
of game matters a lot to you against the
7800 XT there was an enormous 84% uplift
in performance it's undeniable that AMD
is improving in RT at 1440p upscale the
970 XT ran at about the levels of the
RTX 390 the 570 now is 37% ahead so
about the same as last resolution
with the 570 TI 66% ahead reduced from
before the gain on the 970 XT over the
700 XTX is 45% so the same at 1080p
upscale the 9xt held 73 FPS average and
climbed past the 3090 it's now
approaching the 3090 TI which came out 3
years ago and had no formal MSRP at
launch uh it just sold for whatever in
that period kind of like today I guess
and it was typically close to $2,000 but
occasionally 1500 so that's your context
the 570 is now 32% ahead down from 37% 4
the 570 TI is down to 53% ahead still
huge but a gradual reduction step by
step from the 4K upscaled gains of 78%
let's look at something more balanced
Dragon Dogma 2 is a game we'd play with
r tracing enabled we do think it looks
better but it's not nearly as heavy an
implementation cyber Punker black myth
in Dragon Dogma 2 with r tracing and at
4K the RX 970 XT ran at 61 FPS average
this has it ahead of the RTX 570 is 49
FPS result by 26% the 570 TI leads the
97 XT marginally and by 2 FPS or 3.6%
the 700 XTX is about 5 FPS ahead of the
970 XD definitely a healthier position
than Blackmouth but also not as
impressively heavy at 1440p the 970 XT
ran at 103 FPS average and tied the 570
TI almost exactly again this is heavier
on raster than RT but this is a better
result than historically for AMD
previously the 7900 GRE was below the
new 570 with the 7800 XT about the same
as a 4070 TI super 1080p the 970 XD as
still right around the 5070 TI and the
470 TI super d light 2 is up next tested
at 4K with upscaling as the game is
relatively heavy the 970 XT landed at 46
FPS average which puts it tied with the
7800 XTX and just behind the 390 TI AMD
still has a deficit in RTS compared to
its Nvidia competition with the 55070 ti
leading by 24% that's not as obscene as
the Gap in black myth but it's still an
undeniable victory for NVIDIA the RTX
570 ran at 44 f FPS average here so the
970 XT is about 6% ahead 1440p has the
970 XT at 89 FPS average and Ty the 4070
TI super and 3090 TI it's marginally
ahead of the 700 XTX though they're
functionally equal the 5070 TI leads the
9970 XT by 16% now down from 24% at the
higher resolution the 480 super and Fe
were tied with each other and aren't
distant from the 5070 TI at 1080p the
970 XT ran at 129 FPS average the 570 TI
maintains a lead here but it's now
reduced to 99.4% those are some huge
reductions in its Advantage as the
resolution comes down so Nvidia is still
ahead but has lost significant ground
here Resident Evil 4 is up now at 4K
with r tracing and upscaling the 970 XT
performs at parody with 570 TI this is
another of the lighter weight RT titles
so broadly speaking thus far games with
fewer RT features implemented that lean
more heavily on raster allow AMD to
compete better the 970 XT leads the 5070
by 27% with the 7900 XTX leading the 970
XT and this one by 16% at 1440p upscaled
the 970 XT ran at 180 FPS average and
allowed the 5070 TI a marginal Victory
the 9070 XT improved upon the 700 XT but
not the XTX cyberp Punk is up next we'll
start with the heaviest workload and
scale down from there 4K and RT Ultra
tends to destroy cards with lower vram
capacity like the 5070 with its 0.1%
lows cards like the 2070 and 2070 super
have been removed this time since they
were unplayable and their results were
just noise anyway one could be better
than the other just because neither can
play the game the 970 XT landed at 22
FPS average in a relative sense what
matters is that the 5070 TI's lead is
23.5% the 970 XT leads the 570 by 26% in
average FPS but 570 has massive
stuttering problems due to insufficient
vram as it depletes and actually we
showed some video of the screen when we
were running this game test in our 570
review it gets really bad the longer you
play it just it can't keep up bring RT
down to medium but still at 4K the 970
XT runs at 28 FPS average and lands
between the 700 XTX and the 480 it's a
much better spot to be in this puts the
5070 TI ahead by 10% down from 24% at
Ultra you could then get to a playable
frame rate with upscaling or by dropping
the resolution you can see Nvidia
getting embarrassed by its own choices
once again the 4070 TI and 570 are both
crumbling and the 0.1% lows which is a
direct result of the low vrm capacity
this low 0.1% value manifest has
stuttery frame delivery and inconsistent
frame time pacing at 1080p but back to
RT Ultra the 970 XT ran at 71 FPS
average 61 1% low and 58 0.1% lows the
570 encroaches on this result at 64 FPS
average although the 970 XT has a slight
advantage in 0.1% lows the 570 TI leads
the 970 XT here by 20% finally for cyber
Punk tested at 1080P and RT medium the
970 XT ran at 92 FPS average that
reduces the 5070 TI's lead back down to
12% from the 20% we saw with the RT
Ultra uh and same resolution test we're
getting into Power efficiency testing
now efficiency benchmarks are a
combination of power consumption and
performance so you'll get to see both in
this testing we perform the test with a
pmd2 sitting as an interposer between
the PCI slot and the power cables
capturing just the GPU power consumption
and isolation we'll start with Final
Fantasy 14 as usual for this section
however this won't reflect well on the
970 XT due to the overall lower
performance this title the 970 XT ends
up toward the bottom of this chart its
power draw was 310 Watts here pulling
less than the 430 of the 7800 XTX but
also producing a lower frame rate this
drags down the efficiency planted
between the XTX and the 390 TI the 700
XT was more efficient in this particular
test with the 570 likewise significantly
improved on the 970 XT Nvidia remains
advantaged in efficiency 1440p has more
cards on the chart the 9970 XT ends up
improved upon the efficiency of the 6600
XT and the 6700 XT up at 0.45 FPS per
watt but still worse than the prior XTX
7900 XT and nvidia's entire modern
lineup the 570 TI is 62% more efficient
than the 970 XT here up had 0.73 FPS per
watt it's not a good result for AMD it's
burning a lot of power to produce the
output it is here's a better test for
the 970 XT an f124 at 4K with r tracing
the 970 XT ran at 0.18 FPS per watt
these results round to the second place
so different bar sizes for the same
numbers normal it just means that the
hidden digits are separating them anyway
the 970 XT is more efficient than the
570 and significantly more efficient
than amd's prior 700 XT this massive
uplift and flip over the prior raster
Final Fantasy charts comes as a
combination of improved performance of
the power with the large rate tracing
uplift that AMD saw generationally
Nvidia 570 TI however remains more
efficient than the 970 XT at 0.20 FPS
per watt but this is much closer than it
was previously and now only has an 11%
uplift that's it's more normal at 1080p
but still an f124 with rt the 97 XT ran
at 311 watts and scored 0.51 FPS per
watt that puts it ahead of the RTX 460
the Intel b580 and 42% improved on the
prior 7900 XT so that's good Nvidia 570
TI It maintains an advantage though at
266 watts and 0.62 FPS per watt or a 22%
Improvement in fps per watt that benefit
mostly comes from its lower power draw
to produce comparable performance Dragon
stock with two with rt and at 1440p is
up now the 970 XT consumed 311 Watts
during the course of this testing and
calculated to a 0.33 FPS per watt result
which makes it better than the 700 XT
and worse than the 5070 TI despite amd's
gains overall Nvidia retains its
advantage and efficiency and output for
the power used AMD had to get
performance before it could get
efficiency though as these two are part
of the same formula we think their focus
should remain on pumping the performance
numbers with the hope to balance out the
efficiency calculation on that side of
the formula instead star field at 1440p
is up now this is without rate tracing
so this is rasterized and it's one of
the titles that AMD does better in the
970 XT pulled 310 Watts again here
landing at 0.34 FPS per watt and just
ahead of the b570 and 7800 XT the 570
and 5070 TI are both more efficient with
the 5070 TI in particular keeping a
massive Improvement at 0.48 FPS per watt
the performance is comparable on the 970
XD and the 570 TI here meaning that most
of that efficiency benefit comes from
nvidia's card pulling just 209 watts to
produce basically the same amount of
work this is a good comparison because
they're effectively ISO work or
controlled for a a nearly fixed output
and so we've eliminated that last
variable of performance Nvidia is simply
more effective per watt consumed whether
that matters for you is up to you but
we'll talk about that in the conclusion
AMD is definitely winning in the cost
per frame category so sort of that value
perspective but AMD has won there for a
while not news the thing that really
matters is if they're winning by enough
and that's why it was so important that
am to get the price right here Nvidia
currently has about 90% of the discret
GPU Market AMD has the remaining 10
intels at about zero and that's why it's
so important for consumers that AMD and
one day Intel uh are able to really
compete with Nvidia now at the same time
AMD and Intel shouldn't get pity
purchases just because someone should
compete with Nvidia they still have to
earn it so we'll see how the street
prices Shake Scout for the 970 XT and
again the 5070 TI has a problem where
even its partners aren't hitting MSRP so
consumers are getting scalped by the
likes of MSI as a quick recap of
performance in rasterization performance
and at 4K amd's 970 XT is commonly
within the range of 5 to 6% of the 5070
TI with a few breakouts like d light 2
and blackm myth non-rt where the 570 TI
has about a 12% advantage over the 970
XT as we said earlier our Final Fantasy
14 results just don't match what AMD
presented but we also run the newest
version of The Benchmark across all
resolutions and all games that we looked
at performance of the 9070 XT approaches
levels of the 7900 XTX and some
benchmarks and is commonly around 7900
XT levels but often between them broadly
speaking the 970 XT beats the 570 non TI
and these charts shows the summary of
some of the 4K and 1440p results we have
against the 5070 TI uh the non-ti is
obviously below this these charts
illustrate the percent improvement from
a 970 XT to a 57 TI or in other words if
the bar is positive and going to the
right then that's a 570 TI Victory if
it's going to the left then that's where
the 970 XT was ahead as for ra tracing
performance and videos ahead almost
universally in our testing in black myth
it's not even a competition if you
really wanted to play that particular
game and you decided you need RT for it
with these heavy settings you'd
basically need Nvidia in cyberp Punk AMD
Narrows the Gap from previous
generations but Nvidia maintains a large
advantage in games like Dragon stwa 2
with rt the 970 XT looks much more
competitive the extra vram is useful in
some heavy situations such as in
cyberpunk RT with ultra settings where
the 5070 starts to struggle under vram
load and our efficiency testing Nvidia
maintains an advantage overall this is
derived from both FPS and power and in
many of these cases the lower power draw
serves as the stronger part of nvidia's
side of the equation rather than
performance we think amd's focus on
performance before power is The Right
Move power is okay for them it can
obviously be better but running lower
power wouldn't be worth losing
potentially everywhere on performance we
think they made the right decision on
this Balancing Act and they can try to
bring the power down later and this back
and forth we describing is why it's been
so critical for AMD to get its pricing
right in situations where a purchasing
decision between AMD and Nvidia is
unclear for the average consumer not
most people watching this necessarily
but we're talking Mass Market who don't
even know we exist then Nvidia will
often remain sort of the default choice
in the minds of those consumers unless
AMD really gives them a reason to be
paid attention too and for AMD to really
get noticed it has to win in big ways
either in price or in performance but
ideally both with the 970 XT we think
$600 is the minimum that they had to hit
so there's a lot of support for what AMD
is doing right now it is good that they
came down to 600 uh it's just that we do
have to keep in mind what types of cards
these are and Nvidia at any moment I
mean they're it's a powerful company
they kind of snap their fingers and
change the pricing so 600 was the
minimum uh to get some ground swell and
attention that was positive and it
worked if you look around online AMD
leading up to the launch here has had a
lot of positive ground swell and
positive attention and that's a good
thing it achieved that much and there's
been a lot of enthusiasm over the last
few days over the 9070 series which is
also good and a good part of that is in
no small part thanks to Nvidia
up everything they touch it's like the
midest touch except everything they
touch is it turns into a up of some kind
and this is benefiting AMD right now in
a big way so for pricing just briefly we
would have liked to see the 970 XT a
little bit cheaper the main reason is
we'd like to see AMD like really kick in
the doors I mean this is the opportunity
to maximize impact because of nvidia's
external screw-ups and uh so a little
bit cheaper would have helped them there
for appealing to mass Market we're not
talking like the sort of core audience
that GN has and the core audience that
maybe reddits PC Master race or whatever
has uh but really that mainstream like
someone builds a computer once every
five or 10 years or whatever walks into
a Best Buy and you really got to get the
attention of that person if you're AMD
to grow the market share rapidly uh to
just start generating that momentum the
reason it's so much more important now
than normally is because of nvidia's
screw up the 9070 we'll talk about that
separately but that price is weird that
that price doesn't make a whole lot of
sense it is an upsell it looks like
they're trying to push people to the XT
maybe um but that one uh we'll talk
about that in a separate review so
that's for this one thanks for watching
as always subscribe for more go to
store. gam access.net to support us
directly we'll have a lot more to say
about these cards so we'll do some
follow-ups as we see how the priceing
situation shakes out in real time and
subscribe for more we'll see you all
next time